you've heard of Lake Mead but have you
heard of Lake Mohave some call it one of
Las Vegas best-kept secrets rocky got to
hang out with Lake Mead Mojave
adventures to learn why Lake Mohave is
such a refreshing and safe spot to enjoy
the summer it's a beautiful day for
boating here at Lake Mead Mojave
adventures at Willow beach now I see a
dock but I see very few boats why is
that Chad well it seems that boating is
back
so by 7:00 a.m. in the morning
everybody's lined up at the door we've
made reservations in advance they get
their boats and by 9 o'clock they're out
on the lake ok and what are some of the
boats of those type of boats people can
rent from you guys great question so
here at Willow beach we actually have
single passenger kayaks 3 passenger
canoes we have tandem kayaks we have
about 30 what we'd call personal
watercraft if you will are those kayaks
and then we have some motorized vessels
so we have a small fishing skiff we also
have a pontoon boat which you look out
here which goes 8 to 10 passengers will
always remember every boat has a weight
limit then we also have a larger boat
which is called a deck boat and the deck
boat is our largest boat with about 10
passengers ok so how is 3 with the
camera on that boat I think we'll make
it tell me about the vibe here at Lake
Mohave why do people choose to come out
here and just
just coast so the vibe at Lake Mohave is
the best vibe in Nevada
oh all right so Mojave and Lake Meads
sometimes people get confused Lake Mead
is above the dam Lake Mohave is below
the dam we get all the fresh cold water
from Lake Mead so the water that runs
under Lake Mead comes out the bottom of
the dam it's about 51 degrees right now
so whereas Lake Mead warms up in the
summer down here Lake Mohave and Willow
beach the water stays around 51 to 54
degrees year-round so when it gets 110
115 the cold waters a good buy I'm so
lucky people enjoy here other than
getting onto a boat
there's cabanas here that are covered
and managed by the National Park Service
they also have grills at each one of
these I know it's called Willow beach
there's not a lot of sand
I just think back then they didn't
decide to call it willow rock now you're
saying I don't need a license to drive
the boat yeah currently you don't need a
Nevada or an Arizona driver's license to
operate a boat at Willow beach you only
have to watch an 18 minute safety video
yeah watch the video you got the video I
have to do that before the shoe it's
true and because you're here with me oh
god I'd let you drive a little bit ah
driving the boat so right now I'm
imagining myself behind the wheel my
friends sitting here on the couches we
got our music going we got food three
perfect day I'm like so at the end of
each day when anybody comes back from
their boat trip boat trip we now have an
additional protocol for sanitation
that's about a 15 point sanitation
inspection
and we go through that every evening and
let that boat sit overnight and then we
come back in the morning and we do our
traditional cleaning procedures which
were pretty thorough to begin with
before this even happened okay so you
got everything covered now we do we'll
keep you safe out here for sure
so you can get out and boat lake mead
mojave adventures Boulder City for more
information call 877 two six two eight
two one two or visit lake mead mojave
adventures.com beach